co-host of jalen and jacoby the founder
of the jaylen rose leadership academy
and uh one of the top analysts in the
game talking about hoops from
espn nba countdown and more jalen
rose how are you sir thank you for the
love my brother appreciate you having me
on
and as always hail to the victim hail to
the victor's valiant
how about juwan what a season what a
season for him
last year i'm so happy for him and
how he comported himself like the one
thing about joanna
when we were freshman in college
we were the same age but it was like he
was always like
four or five years older than everybody
else
well especially me i guess i should
speak for myself
and in taking the job
the first season and really coming after
john beeline who did a great job
you know we were we were irrelevant for
a long time basketball wise
and john beeline put us back on the map
he started recruiting players that
turned into three four-year players
that now have become really good pros
like duncan robinson trey
burke tim hardaway jr and uh
like for him to take the baton the way
he has
and you know i was disappointed in the
ucla loss
[Laughter]
you know i was at the game i went to a
couple of ncaa tournament games and of
course
as a fan and a crazy alum i'm gonna
always be hurt when we don't go
undefeated and win it all
but having the number one recruiting
class and
being in the living room the top players
and top
um transfers and like having that
respectability back for the program
really feels good and i'm really happy
that uh
he brought that back well especially
since we all know jalen we heard about
he can't
the michigan shouldn't in terms of his
hiring and what does he
you know that he he paid his dues as an
assistant
uh in the association but you know he's
never done this at college and
he was smart enough to reach out to phil
martelly and he's smart enough to
to be and believe in himself and uh
and what he did last year was remarkable
and now we're already hearing
like you know celtics jobs open who
wouldn't want to coach you know uh
jaylen brown and jason tatum
the portland's job uh is open and who
wouldn't want to maybe take a run at
damian lillard you're hearing his name
mentioned already how
concerned should i be do you think jalen
here well well he's a professional and
there's a price of doing business
and you and i both know you can really
love your college
but if one of those situations come with
a blank check
you got to reconsider your life that's
just how this works
and the kind of money that coaches have
been getting
look at matt rules con
he went from college to the pros he got
a major deal
uh the kind of money that collegiate
coaches are getting and professional
elite level coaches are getting is
astronomical
but i know his heart is in ann arbor
i know that he wants to bring a national
championship
back to the school and we do have the
number one recruiting class coming in
next year and i know he's excited he and
the staff of coaching
and so i i would tell you to breathe
easy
that i anticipate that he'll still be
with us for the foreseeable future
and uh committed to doing all of the
things he said at his initial press
conference jaylen rose here
on the rich eisen show uh and we'll put
a pin in the
uh wolverine conversation for a second i
want to circle back
well i mean girl listen to us talk about
michigan okay i i i couldn't i'll just
joke
no i know that i want to put a pin in it
just for the moment because i
i i could do all of that and uh you know
there is so much going on in the
playoffs as well i know you are too
jalen you're you're the best man
um so uh i it's seeing the way the nets
have performed without harden
he's just played just one minute and
they have just absolutely
spanked the bucks um what what
what what makes us think anybody could
take care of the nets once hardened does
potentially
come back in these playoffs as we assume
he will uh despite how significant this
hamstring injury could be
read me this situation so i can't front
i'm disappointed in the books
i actually picked them to win this
series and if james harden go out the
first minute of the first quarter
it's one thing to lose that game okay
blake griffin was kaiser jose in detroit
you surprised that he back duncan now
got it okay you didn't understand that
joe harris was
you know one of the best catch and shoot
players we have in the league
okay bang he got going we know what k.d
and kyrie can do
they were amazing they're magicians when
they get going especially in one-on-one
situations
okay i'll give you game one but then you
come on game two and you're trailing by
49
points at some point of the game that's
just unacceptable
and they have the back-to-back reigning
mvp and giannis
who i voted for when he won the mvp and
defensive player of the year
and the the one thing about this season
and i also picked the bucks to win this
series
i was betting on chemistry i was betting
on cohesion
i talked about them adding drew holiday
and believing in middleton
but the elephant in the room is once the
playoffs start
giannis can't make shots outside of the
paint
he's made five he's like five or 35
outside of the paint in the playoffs
he's 23 for 43
from the free-throw line the game is so
tough when your best player a superstar
player can't make shots
and then on the other end with kd doing
his double crossover and
hitting his loud um step back jumper and
getting the and one that was over
giannis
and then when tyreese stroll up like he
had rucker park and do the same thing
that was over giannis
and when blake griffin dunking again
that was over jonas and so as this is
happening the rest of your roster and
team and coaches see this too and you
become so demoralized that you get beat
the way they got beat in game two
so i think effort is gonna um be there
for the bucks in game three
i anticipate they're gonna win game
three but i wanna make sure i
celebrate the greatness of kd and kyrie
true enough
but i can't act like i wasn't severely
disappointed
in how the bucks played both games when
they were in brooklyn
so then let's just say uh you will be
ultimately disappointed by the bucks
and hardin just in the middle of your
answer was ruled out for game three
um who who can dispatch with the nets
is it a sixers team should they get past
the hawk could the hawks do it if they
proved to be so plucky or is it somebody
in the west or nobody
give me your answer on that your first
blush response
here's the thing if you're the eastern
conference and you're the field
and you can't beat the nets without
james harden
you know you're really in trouble the
next few years
so i want to believe if james harden
doesn't come back
and he's not healthy against
philadelphia who i anticipate
will beat atlanta who outplayed
expectations
so far and continue to do so and trae
young and bogdanovic have been
outstanding
but uh like
the the nets are
the net shouldn't be beating teams by 49
points
and you would hope as a professional
team they shouldn't advance
in the east without james hart
and so i want to believe the balance of
philly would embed
post-ups um simmons and fibel's
defensive ability
milton and curry shot making abilities i
i i would hope just because that philly
can play multiple styles that they
should be able to beat the nets
especially if james harden isn't playing
jalen rose here on the rich eisen show
co-host of jalen jacoby from espn nba
countdown and again the founder of the
jaylen rose leadership academy which i
want to talk about in a second here
on the rich eisen show fellow michigan
man rob polinka should do what
this off season just sit back and say
let's just get everybody healthy
run it back i like the changes that i
made the bubble
uh affected pretty much everybody and
maybe even the mvp of the league
uh jokic might feel the results
shortly but uh or or do they have to
make significant changes here
in los angeles they won't make
significant changes because
none of the cornerstones will be
uprooted
not rob um who's already as we know won
a championship with them i don't think
it's going to be
there won't be any change with frank
vogel and obviously won't be any change
with lebron and nate d
so as you dig deeper into the roster
it's like
okay are we going to resign dennis
schroeder he turned down the 80 million
dollar deal
he didn't perform well in the playoffs
and it's never good when magic johnson
tweets that you're not a laker that's
just not good for negotiation that's
correct
it's not good for negotiations um
and so you look at dennis schroeder and
then you look at montreal's hero who
have the player option
he went from the clippers to the lakers
he thought he was going to increase his
value he decreased his value
so he probably uh op back in to i
believe 9 mil
next year and then the third piece is
kyle kuzma who most people
should remember that he's an asset
like he was taken late in the first
round
um you lose ball you lose ingram
you still hold on to him and all of a
sudden he becomes a rotation player
not a consistent player but his game
just isn't an equal fit with lebron and
a.d
up front it just like they're gonna it's
just not an equal fit so
those are the three players schroeder
montrez hero
and kyle kuzma if they're gonna be like
any changes to their rotational players
other than the guys they picked up late
like an andre drummond
you know mark the soul guys that you
know they pick up as they get bought out
or
you know get disgruntled at another
situation so i say you stay patient you
stay pat
it's just a wide open championship this
year you still hope to have a healthy
lebron
and uh you hope in theory you can rely
on a.d
for the entire regular season that's the
biggest question mark all right jaylen
rose in the few minutes i have left with
you let's get into the leadership
academy what's going on
how can we help today we actually have a
senior barbecue from one to five it's a
little rainy outside i don't know if you
heard me pause
but i literally looked outside and like
it's raining i can't believe it because
it wasn't raining
when i just walked in the house but
we're open enrollment we're tuition free
we're public charter
founded the school in 2011. we're
non-profit
a couple of things that make us unique
and special is that we're nine through
16 model
so we have 400 plus scholars in high
school and have another
500 which will be 600 plus when this
year's graduates happen that's amazing
secondary education there's college of
military community
college of military community college
trade school and so um we're a 9 through
16 model and i'm really proud that our
graduation is going to be this saturday
and uh we graduate approximately i think
83
young people this this year as well and
so i'm really just excited about
the the the the students and the
the families building believing in my
vision all of the donors
um we have an amazing board i have an
amazing co-founder
it's been a labor of love and i truly
appreciate a lot of the sponsors but
we're taking sports
and we're also influencing the community
because
tom goers and the pistons they've been a
terrific supporter they've been a
terrific donor
and they've committed to help with our
expansion
and so steven ross the owner of the
miami dolphins
of course is also committed to
contribute
to our expansion and so and
big shout out to the davis elkin
foundation as well and to jeep
who've all been terrific sponsors so
being a non-profit
and and being tuition-free we get zero
state funding for our facility
zero state funding so i took an
elementary school and converted it into
a high school
and so now our goal is to expand get
more classrooms get a college-sized gym
and uh i'm really excited about the
progress of the school and when you in
the city
i got to give you a tour man i love it
you got to come check out the students
no i would i would love it will you
already know about the show
i would really love it i would love it
i really i really would um you know and
people could go to jrla detroit.com to
learn more about this uh this jewel
in northwest detroit on the great state
of michigan i'm so proud to see you
doing this jalen and what you've done
with
your platform and what you're doing with
your platform it means so much and
now that's where i want to remove the
pin on the michigan chat i saw you and c
webb chatting on the worldwide leader in
sports and i got to tell you it it gave
me
a pleasure i i couldn't have been more
happy it gave me a big smile
um and i saw that c webb told dan
patrick that the two you still need to
get into a room
how can i can i do that for you can i
get you a room can is that is that need
to happen
with you and chris just get a just get
just just make it a presidential
and order a lot of champagne and order a
lot of lobster
and let us sit there for 30 minutes and
then we invite
the other three members of the crew in
and put us all in black and white
zoot suits and big hats with big
feathers okay
and show how he's winning the score of
the game and the game of life
so that's it you just need do you need a
couple of minutes is that
would you agree with that assessment
that the two of you still need a couple
minutes
to hash something out well i can't i
can't like
well he well here here's the overarching
point the overarching point is that
we're long time
friends that became brothers and there
have been some turbulent
times days weeks months years in our
relationship
but we're still family and so he and i
want to iron it out
our goal is to iron it out i believe we
will iron it out
and there will be a time there's gonna
be a time
there's going to be a time when we're in
ann arbor michigan
and i'm gonna have a fresh cut
and i'm gonna be suited and booted like
i'm supposed to
and we're gonna be watching juwan howard
coach the team to a victory
gosh i'm confident that that's gonna
happen
shout to ray jackson shout out to jimmy
king it's gonna happen
i i i can't wait for something like that
to happen jalen and then i guess to just
wrap it all
up you've mentioned style and fashion
and uh and it's very important when we
are talking about the fab five and
that's how i want to turn things over to
my social media grand maester tj
jefferson
to ask you about what he asked juwan
about just a few weeks ago tj i will
give you the floor in the few minutes we
have left with jalen please go for it
hey what up jalen
what up though so you know it's funny
man if you told me back in 1991 when i
was sitting in press row
watching you drop 20 points in
pittsburgh at the dapper dan game
then the year 2021 we'd be on the rich
eisen show hear that
if he played that game just as big as
the mcdonald's game
yes indeed that's one of my favorite
games and i saw it i was there i was
a baseline if i recall correctly and uh
watched you do your thing so if you had
told me in 2021 we'd be on the rich
eisen show
on peacock talking i mean my mind's
blown away right he said what do you
mean by that too in that day too
okay i mean so crazy but jalen you know
crazy way back in those days bro i know
for a fact that
well not for a fact i heard that you
know you really wanted spandex under
your shorts because the shorts were too
short they didn't give it to you
and i'm sure you didn't put in all that
work at basketball city in detroit
to to make these shorts longer the way
you guys did and as you being the
architect of the fab five look
you got those baggy shorts and it turned
everybody
in the world onto that look and now
these kids man they're
i don't know if it's crossfit and
they're happy with what their quads look
like but these
shorts man they're they're heading up
north they're getting a little tight
they're getting a little short i talked
to jaylen then sorry i talked to chris
and joanne about it
so i could ask jalen how do you feel
about these shorts creeping up the thigh
so don't tell anybody but i was born in
the 70s
and that's how my favorite players
growing up
used to wear them when i was watching
the game
and so whether it's magic bird like
dr j isaiah thomas
like he he dennis rodman and john
stockton probably had classic shorts
yeah they did yeah
like it was it was like almost like soft
porn with
all of these cameras available like
imagine shaq with some small
shorts i can't i can't i'm falling down
right
he'd be bursting out on things like the
incredible hulk
and so i i believe that
fashion transcends and by the way
check out renaissance man every thursday
a column i write for the new york post
and the podcast that i release
yes i'm very happy to report that we
were recently top 10 in the united
states
had some great great guests on there and
on that i talked
fashion in entertainment and lifestyle
and what ends up happening is we think
we're inventing something but it's
already been seen
how many times you guys been in the car
lit with a younger person
and they're listening to a song like
it's the first time that that song that
beat has been made
so if i say keep sweat on tv they may be
young but they're ready
people think that i'm singing beyonce
right right and so that's what make it a
good
like good catch phrase because you
grabbed two audiences with it
but back to what you were saying and
what ends up happening
is when people see that one look got
mastered a lot of people that are
creative think well imma
i'm gonna go another direction i'm gonna
switch it up i'm gonna flip
it and so i was like okay they were long
there i'm aware
you saw various college players try to
do it like there's a young man
big shout out to memphis and penny
harter where i joke with him when he was
on
our show about this one he has a guy on
his team that wears the really small
shorts and one time he had a breakaway
layup and he missed it
and i promise it was because of the
shorts
you know what i mean i'm like yo he just
got you know saying
y'all fella got loosened up you know
what i'm saying let these things breathe
gotta go in there strong and finish that
and so
i i think it's that also but
it and now things are more aerodynamic
like you look back and think like look
at lebron's oversized suit when he got
drafted or
look at some of the nba players when
they were on night shows in the 90s and
stuff like that
tj ford was wearing culottes correct
they were oversized and how about a guy
that went to the draft with a red white
pinstripe suit with some red maury
gators
right he was looking fresh to death
though jay do you think somebody's gonna
take you in the top three dressed like
that
like did you what were you thinking you
know what i'm saying
but either way we're seeing it right now
jalen
we got up on the screen look at that
look oh my gosh
denver nuggets by the way if it's a
really big picture
i had like a pimple underneath my eye
that i was trying to pop
all night and it's just like a spot on
my face
it seems like that always happens on the
big stage something like that happens
when you grow up in the hood never been
to the dentist never been to the
dermatologist
and you're about to get drafted tomorrow
you got jerry cross on one phone
and you got the alcohol in your hand
trying to pop a bunk
and so um for for
for the young people to switch up the
shorts
it's just because they're just trying to
change the game a little bit
you know but i i appreciate you know
the influence we have had on the game we
continue to have on the game
but it's sparked by the people sparked
by the culture
and it was birthed by people still
believing in us
at that time and rich you know this as
well as anyone obviously if you saw me
at dapper dan you definitely
know that i i'm glad that i've seen
the cosmic shift of being disliked and
hated
to being appreciated because if you
do a list of most hated college
basketball players
i'll probably be on it and i feel like
i'm a likable person
jaylen rose everybody what an answer
that's what's up
jalen thanks for the call best tamale uh
loves seeing what she's up to these days
man sen
send our best to uh to your wife i love
you my brother i appreciate the love
don't hesitate to reach out about
anything i will do that you same to you
that's jaylen rose everybody the one and
only
what an answer i love you knew he'd give
you that answer yeah
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here